sourire j'ai trouvé le slogan c'est
ensemble première photo de famille
premier slogan alexandra cordier ex
référente départementale la république
en marche et candidate malheureuse à
l'investiture du parti mènera donc bien
une liste pour les municipales de
besançon une liste sans étiquette
même si alexandra cordy est soutenue par
l'actuel maire la république en marche
jean louis fousseret personne ne
revendiquera sur cette liste une
appartenance à un mouvement c'est notre
choix et la volonté c'est d'être une
liste sans étiquette ouverte de
rassemblement pour représenter un
maximum de personnes vous avez des
contacts avec la famille marche les
liens sont à couper si les liens avec la
république en marche ne sont pas coupés
la question dérange d'autant plus que le
55e nom sur la liste ensemble est celui
de jean louis fousseret l'un des
soutiens de la première heure des
manuels matheron n'est pas une trahison
puisque nous faire les choses autrement
nous voulons répondre aux aspirations
des bisontines épisode r je pense qu'il
ya besoin ici à besançon comme dans
beaucoup d'autres villes de faire en
sorte ou pas c'est chose faite être
autrement face au parc des partis
politiques qui décident les coupes à
venir des gens la société civile
outre l'actuel maire de besançon il y
aura aussi sur la liste ensemble
philippe gonon sans son étiquette
politique agir et le médiatique avocat
randall schwerdorffer dix places restent
encore ouvertes pour qui voudrait
rejoindre cette équipe dans la campagne
des municipales les alliances ont donc
tendance
eric alauzet candidat officiel la
république en marche se réjouit
d'accueillir sur sa liste laurent
croizier chef de file du modem
mais quand il s'agit de commenter
l'annoncé d'une liste dissidente menée
par alexandra cordier toujours adhérente
en marche
les mots sont à peine feutrée l'un comme
l'autre on s'y est engagé sur l'honneur
à soutenir le candidat investi par le
mouvement et que pour tous les gens qui
sont autour de moi
la parole c'est encore du sens la
logique pour vous ce serait quelques
elle quitte le mouvement républicain
marc ça si on ne s'est pas la question
du jour on y reviendra sans doute à
besançon la bagarre pour les municipales
s'annonce rude premiers arbitrages dans
les urnes le 15 mars prochain